she was cleaning man we got home she was
cleaning the whole house nobody had been
in our house
nobody was there nobody there
we got to behave we gotta clean
sanitize we got i go damn baby took a
pandemic
to get you to clean
he is one of the country's fastest
rising comics and embodies the title of
america's favorite husband and you can
catch his debut performance over at the
mirage as part of their aces of comedy
lineup it's steve trevino
welcome thank you
i am
i'm wearing my dad's shirt
you know the ultimate dad and ultimate
husband i just think you are such a
great husband and i was telling you off
the air the things you say just
it sounds like i'm listening to my
husband you say everything that i think
every man who's nervous wants to say
well it's a documentary yeah you know
and i do it all on stage so that maybe
my wife sees what i'm saying and changes
but none of it works that was from your
pandemic special how was that for you it
was it was scary but i knew that there
was a moment in our life in our times
that we needed to do it so i just wanted
to talk about what was going through
mine in my wife's mind during the
pandemic and you know we were able to do
this special in front of a socially
distanced audience with a mask and it
was just something that that i had i saw
the opportunity we took it and it just
turned out to be amazing you know and
and without giving away too much of the
special how was pandemic life for you
too well you know it it i always and i
say it in the thing it was it was um a
change in the routine right you know
i would come home
we would
i'd go back on the road we'd miss each
other i'd come home
so there was no opportunity to miss each
other
we were together all the time you know
now here you are in vegas and a lot of
people are like yeah vegas i'm gonna
hang out with the boys but you're here
with your wife yes absolutely i'm always
with my wife and it's it's funny because
i'll answer the phone in the car or
something on speaker and and everybody
knows they're like oh hi renee
cause they know she's always with me
she's always by my side and a very good
friend of ours told us one time he said
you know if you're with your wife you
can't get in trouble this is a wise man
right here and i and i learned the new
move here in vegas i bought her a purse
before i started gambling
and she was so much happier it was
perfect but she's not going to tell you
to go back to the room like you got me
the prayers you're totally fine talk
about performing here in vegas i mean
aces of comedy over at the mirage that
that is top tier that is the dogs man
you know what it is it is really
overwhelming and to see the lineup that
aces of comedy brings in and for me to
be a part of that lineup has just been
really freaking cool you know and and
we're almost sold out which is even more
exciting and it's just been an amazing
experience and the whole staff at mgm i
mean at um mirage has just been
absolutely amazing and accommodating and
it's funny because they're like well
what do you want and i'm like i i don't
know
yeah they go we'll give you whatever you
want you know you want rooms you want
you know and i'm just like i'm just
happy to be here
you know and it's so humble it really is
an honor it really is an honor let me
ask you about hecklers i've always
wondered about this when you're on stage
and there's someone in the audience and
they're like ah say whatever have you
had to deal with that before well i i do
but in a different way i i have the
positive heckler
i have the they love me so much that
they're ruining the show
you know you know what i mean
yes he said this yes captain evil you
know
and the whole time i'm like okay i know
you love the show but you don't know how
to love the show
you're annoying everybody around you
with your love for me thank you but but
yeah we get the the woo girl
i feel like that was me in the green
room
but you know even that you know i'm
walking around the mirage today and
you know it really is overwhelming i
mean people stop and they want to take a
picture or or they come up to me and and
they're sometimes they're a little
nervous you know can i get a picture
with you and i'm like yeah i mean
i feel like i'm the the lucky one oh
well you are hilarious i love your
podcast with your wife my life in
quarantine it's now available on amazon
you can check out steve trevino
performing live here in vegas at the
mirage this thursday is december 9th
part of the aces have come